so pregame today it looked like
we're okay let's uh flat and love you
man yeah whoa whoa but that's not manoa
yeah no no yeah and that's hernandez
yeah
it's a fraternity that's right how
you're ribs by the way that's what
guerrero is telling matt harvey
well trying to get back on track you
know seven losses in a row
three wins before that two seamer maybe
not sinking as much
as they say it is bounce to short
galvest
and one downs
benches and bullpens clear this a lazy
fly ball to right field
austin hayes out there for the second
out
as guerrero lines one into right field
takes that outside fastball the other
way for a two out single
runner at first two down and hernandez
bounces one to third
charging franco off balance throw not in
time
hernandez will beat it out for an
infield hit and guerrero to second on
the play
up high ball four went with a slider
missed up above the zone and that's
going to load him up for cabin bizio
and now he's 3-2 on vicio no place
to go swung on and misty got him so matt
harvey survives the first the blue jays
leave them loaded orioles coming to bat
no score
dungeon ryu will get the start this is
going to be his 14th start of the season
and he just hasn't been right
his last couple of starts trey mancini
coming up in this
nothing nothing game hit well center
field grichik racing back
running out of room it's out of here
happy father's day
tony trey mancini just talking jim
hadn't
hit a lot of home runs this month there
goes number 13. he's back in the
club lead tied with cedric mullins
1-2 swung on grounded down to third
espinal the second one
simeon to first for the double play that
ends the inning
santiago espinal flies out to right
field and now reese maguire hits one a
long way
up against the fence on a bounce in deep
left center
first pitch swinging maguire's got
himself a two out double
and down he goes so a strikeout
semi and down orioles come with a bat on
top
one nothing
breaking ball swatted into the left
galvest comes through with two strikes
as guriel picks it up near the foul line
swing and a miss severino strikes out
and ryu gives up a base hit with nothing
more
[Applause]
pachette sky high does anybody see it
yeah franco coming in
and makes the catch that's a tough look
well pedro had no idea where it was he's
got the father's day blue
harvey wanted nothing to do with it and
mancini had too far to come i think
and he got him looking oh outside corner
he didn't think
he's not going to argue but you know
you're always looking for a little help
and
we told you he rediscovered the slider
up the middle backhand side veleka fires
across
great throw and he gets him so a one two
three inning just what
harvey needed
a good swing by guriel lines it to right
center field and he's got himself a two
out double here in the fourth
boy what a pretty swing that was
strike away from getting out of this
inning 2-2 on the way
and he got him breaking ball strikeout
there's a good pitch right there from
ryu fastball up and away to pick up the
second out
and gets a ground ball to third easy
play for espinal and it's another three
up three down inning
for hyunjin ryu
meanwhile reese maguire having himself a
day as he lines one into the right
center field gap
and maguire is now two for two with a
couple of doubles today
infield in for the orioles the batter
bow bashed
and he loops it into right field that'll
be a base hit to get maguire home
hayes place it in the corner to hold a
bow to a single but that has driven in a
run
and it's a 1-1 game now in the fifth
3-2 and down and away ball four so the
blue jays
with two on with one out now for te
oscar hernandez
tay oscar's back today and he has been
hot stay oscar hernandez lines one
that's a fair ball
down the left field line beshett is
going to score
guerrero will stop it third on an rbi
double by hernandez
and the blue jays now lead two to one
things the blue jays
have taken advantage of matt harvey here
in the fifth can randall gretchen keep
it going
a swing and a liner into center that's a
base hit
guerrero into score hernandez will be
held to third in rbi
single for grichik it is three to one
and now cabin bizio with the runners on
the corners and one out
[Applause]
vicio with a fly ball shallow left
center field and it's off the glove of
mount castle
hernandez in the score around a third on
the play comes grichik that'll be an rbi
single for biggio it is four to one so
that'll end the day
for matt harvey orioles with a pitching
change in the blue jays with a 4-1 lead
well adam butko will come in and try to
extricate if the orioles out of this jam
blue jays on every base a ball and two
strikes two down
and it's strike three looking so they
get
maguire to end the inning but a big
inning for the blue jays as they take
the lead
as galvez swings through a pitch over
the outside corner
for the first out of the inning the 2-2
to michael
franco swing and a miss on a cutter down
and in
back-to-back strikeouts for ryu getting
some more movement on his pitches
he's starting to hit those edges of the
strike zone again
4-1 blue jays bottom six and again the
3-2 pitch
and it is lined to center field grichik
is there to make a nice running catch
two down
[Applause]
as mount castle lifts the first pitch to
left field
guriel back but has room on the warning
track
and the ballpark holds it the orioles go
in order four one j's at the end of six
and a good changeout grounded deep in
the hole at short long throw buchet
dug out by guerrero for the out pitch
number 100
on the afternoon could be his final one
if he gets galveston ends the inning
right here
and a ground ball to second to an east
simeon on to first
and it's a three up three down inning
seven very strong
innings for hyunjin ryu today curiel jr
will lead it off for the blue jays one
for three had a double back in the
fourth inning and he hooks the first
pitch he sees
down the left field line of fair ball
guriel on his way to second and in there
with his second extra base hit of the
afternoon
and reese maguire just two for three
with a couple of doubles and a run score
and he puts another good swing on the
ball lines it into the right field
corner
guriel is going to come into score
maguire head first into second
with his third double of the afternoon
now bo buchet
runner at second two down and the 01.
[Applause]
and he lines it to left center field and
that's going to drop for a base hit in
front of mount castle and maguire's
going to come in to score
it's an rbi single for buchet and that
makes it six to one
and pedro is severino come up to bat now
that's it well yeah there you go pedro
been a long time
yeah no a bad flip well kind of bad
flipping all the way down to first base
so home run number three for pedro
severino memorial score for the first
time since the first inning
so it'll bring up trey mancini he has
the other home run in this game
the set in the pitch and mancini hits it
in the air right field and deep
this shield going back on the track out
of room
orioles have made it a two run game it's
a two
homer day for trey mancini and it is now
six to four toronto the ball keeps
flying out of camden yards for the o's
and for trey that's career run number
100
it comes in a time when the orioles
needed it badly
three run eighth inning
as grichik drops one into right field
for a lead off base hit
reese mcguire today sorry
three for four with three doubles 1-0
and a liner into right field a base hit
the fourth hit of the game for maguire
grichik in to score and it is seven to
four blue
jays wire trying to encourage him one
ball
two strikes the count
and a ground ball to short bashat has it
throw to first
and the blue jays will win it chatwood
comes
in and gets three ground ball outs gets
the baseball
as he picks up the save this afternoon
hyunjin ryu pitches very well
seven strong innings and what a day for
reese mcguire